y'a pas de rivière championnat et
mitrailleuses la bourse et aux régies ce
travail au glaive et aujourd'hui nous
expliquer comment ils montrent un mur en
pierres sèches
des gens vont commencer les femmes
nettoyer au terrain désormais à
seulement viser les adventices commence
à préparer les galets dans les landes
alentours au matériel d'outils open line
air tarom bâtiment c'est naturel
parce que moi il faut bien dans la masse
aussi les gens ils utilisent on y va du
bien qui les rend plus les biens du
krill des furies m'amuse en minimes
st-gall d'un libre échange de regards le
terrain s'il est stable et les plats
puis les plats les meilleurs font monter
la tsh est bon là là les paillis d'entre
nous montre une autre et nous fait les
tranchées déjà pouvoir stabiliser les
galets plus il fallait trancher les prix
y est on pour l'acter verra si on est là
c'est bien pierre était ainsi de suite
et surtout choisir des pierres sur les
viols assez assez bien bien joli bien
car vu bien formés je vous fais ça avec
une humeur sous la main
il
bien positionné le gall et des gens
répondent qu'ils allaient bon dalli a vu
maman notre foi mais moi aussi je rame a
été déjà prince et puis bon ben j'ai
monté trois le cas je suis donc seul eu
des discussions au seulement c'est
toujours par mon endroit
on va avoir une bonne aspect le galet et
ainsi de suite et bien phrase ici
car comme elle bloque américains lors il
a beaucoup de fonds mais ce n'est qu'on
appelle donc aux douanes et le ballet
façon
le critère pour vous voyez nous remonte
le moral ont peu à peu une remblais il
ya pour stabilise le galet pour paris
des formes parce que sinon ça légale m a
donné la plus tendance tombe d'ailleurs
à
parce que donc moi s'en rendre compte à
des gens bien plus rares
ben l'on va patienter rocher c'est comme
un drainage
parce que s'il n'y a pas d'ouverture
l'hôte du style à l'intérieur raconte
et tout ça sans pack 3 décembre comme
avions d'ici là racing et almaty donc
voir mario signer les rochers
on dit c'est le rocher donc légalisera
mieux
mieux fixe est bienvenu après c'est quoi
le résultat par maman ne sais pas si
vous avez remarqué pour égaler son parc
je suis si quelqu'un qui fait preuve
dont le ballet c'est pas comme si c'est
comme ça quoi
l'embellissement du paysage peint pour
les gens de l'île de la réunion qui
passait bien voici ceux ci étaient
occupés à nettoyer et à la portée d hier
que les agences sont là boulot voilà
elle fait plaisir quand quelqu'un soit
en france ou quelque part ailleurs que
dans l'île de la réunion il va monter à
la montagne mais ils voient bien ce beau
paysage pas tous les fleurir et bien
entretenu longtemps qu'on nous montre
dans l'hérault c'était pas pury company
nous indique à chaque tirage que vous
passez le client et les gens les gens il
y avait qu à nous décevoir les gens ya
claudia nous il ya les traiterons
travail
je voudrais que les gens qu'on envoie
gentillement dans les rangs j'essaierai
de chat un petit peu les des trucs à la
levée des voitures parce que c'est nous
qui ramasse et